[Music]
tk apprentice is it worth knowing knight
and bishop checkmate yeah so it's worth
knowing the w pattern and i think the
mostly it's worth knowing not because
it's going to bring you success but
because i almost feel like the fear of
not being able to do it will actually
damage you in more ways than you realize
you might get positions which ultimately
don't result in the mate but because
you're afraid of not knowing how to do
it you're going to think about it so
it's just worth learning once
and then that's and practicing from time
to time and then you just can feel like
more of a professional player
phase one is the hardest phase
phase one is getting the king into the
corner that is what causes a lot of
people thrown that is what causes gm
straw what causes meat it causes
everybody to travel because it is
actually hard against good resistance
now
what is the goal the ultimate goal is
very simple you want to get the king
into the same color corner as your
bishop that's you have to do that
there's no other way to mate with
animation you must get the king into one
of two corners either this one
or this one the ones highlighted in
green in under 50 modes right because of
the 50 merbel if a pawn is not moved or
capture isn't made in 50 moves the game
is declared draw i did at one point try
to design like a way to teach how to get
the king into the corner the bottom line
is that the bishop is
very often used as the close quarter
combatant and the knight is used as the
perimeter defender so in this position
there's a couple of important techniques
to know that help you get the king into
the corner and the phase one involves
getting the king onto the back rank any
of the back ranks any four of them
doesn't matter which one doesn't matter
which corner if it's the right corner
great
but even if it's the wrong corner that's
the hard part and then all you have to
learn is one specific technique and once
you learn it it really is automatic so
what should white do here how should
white begin and there's a couple of a
couple of ways to do it but in my
opinion the best is to put the bishop on
e4 this is what i refer to this as peace
assisted opposition so it's like
opposition on steroids where you're
actually pushing the king back using the
bishop to push the king back this should
make sense so even without the knight
this pushes the king back
so whichever way the king goes you
pursue the king you go like king d4
okay but people get into this situation
and then they're like super confused
about what to do so a lot of people here
would go like this but but this lets the
king like you don't want to let the king
roam free about the cabin you want to
control the black king kind of push it
lightly toward one side of the board
so one good thing to do here would be to
go knight b5 that would make sense to me
you knight as the perimeter defender
right knight defends the squares from a
distance so if the king goes back then
it's all easy if the king goes back to
d7 e7 or f7 then you approach with your
king obviously and here you've already
succeeded in like nudging the king to
the seventh ring but what's the most
resilient defense for black what's yeah
so king of six black is gonna try to
what black is gonna try to do here is
sort of run
behind the white pieces and then back
toward the center ultimately the black
king is going to have to stick close to
the center in order to defend
resiliently but now what you can do
and this is admittedly
a very hard move um well no this is not
the easiest move is just king d5 and
this is called shouldering right you're
using your king again you're nudging the
black king
to one side right king g5 and now king
e5 and again you've already gotten the
king
one file away from one of the corner
files
now black has only one defensive attempt
which is to run the king all the way
around
through e3 or through e1 and go the
other way so what you have to do now and
this is a good idea you have to keep
track of how where the opponent's king
ultimately can escape you're not worried
about the black king going back up to g5
you can deal with that so you need to
think and say okay where do i want my
knight to close off
uh the king's escape route and if you
think logically it's actually quite
simple so imagine
the black king on f2 think about that
imagine the whoa before you say any
moves that way too early to say move
imagine the black king on f2
from f2 like what how can an access to
center well it can go to e3 we can deal
with that if our king is on f4 and our
king is already one square it can go to
e2
we can deal with that by putting a
knight on c3 at the right moment and it
can go through e1
but if it goes through e1 and we have a
knight on c3 then we can go king f4 to
e3
and lock the king in so essentially all
we need to do
well we can put a knight on c3
immediately we can make a waiting move
too
but the simplest is to play knight c3
so we start with this if king g5 then
you guys already know the technique
what's the correct move here
here you should you should know the move
automatically and you've already
succeeded phase one is accomplished
after bishop about five
yeah phase one is accomplished so
same with king h3 or any any move other
than king g3
what should white do now now we continue
shouldering the black king now we
continue shouldering the black king you
want to guide it in the right direction
so now that we are armed with the
machinery
to trap the king once it gets to f2 you
go king f5 right you stop the king from
dilly dallying around and going between
g4 and three and once king f2 has
happened
that's it we go king of four just as we
discussed the knight is guarding e2 very
important if the knight was not on c3
the king would have been able to escape
via e2 and d2 king k1 king e3 boom
we've succeeded phase one is
accomplished now not only is it
accomplished but the way that we have
assumed black will defend we've already
succeeded in phase two
which is
well phase two is an intermediate phase
where you get your knight and bishop
onto the right squares in order to
accomplish the w and the w is a
particular night maneuver that allows
you to get the enemy king from an
undesirable corner to a desirable corner
in order to we'll get back to this
position specifically but in order to
understand how to proceed in this
position let's talk about the w overall
so let me paste in another position
where
we have a situation where the black king
is on
an undesirable corner so let's say we
still have a light skirt bishop but the
king is all the way in in a dark corner
so the w is very simple
so let's take this position and the w is
obviously applicable to any like any
pathway right you can do it on any
corner but the board is symmetrical so
this the the
principle is simple it's easy to
understand
the knights will control the dark
squares the bishops will control the
squares of its own color so you're going
to alternate the knight is going to
control h8 then the bishop is going to
control g8
then the knight's going to control f8
then the bishop is going to control e8
etc etc etc until you
shepherd the king to the other side of
the board
so the w starts on
it it starts on f7 right it starts on f7
that's the only square from which you
can control h8 and you can draw the w
back to e5 toward d7 back to c5 and
toward b7 a w shape so you're going to
go f7 to e5 to d7 to c5 potentially to
b7 that's the complete w depending on
how black defends you might need to make
a little bit of some changes based on
common sense
people get already incredibly confused
because they get confused when we
reflect this about
the about an axis if the black king
starts here and you want to get it there
the w is drawn a little bit differently
but it's still the freaking w just
starts on b3 and goes like this
the w ends you can draw it by
understanding that it ends one square
diagonally away
from the mating square from the square
of the right corner right so
here and then you can draw it backward
if you want okay so if you're trying to
get the king from a1 to a8
okay boom
okay boom boom boom boom
if we're trying to get the king from a1
to h1
boom um
boom boom boom boom
it's really not that hard
right
and that's one way just to draw the w
mind so
what we need to do first
is get the knight onto f7
without allowing the black king to
escape right so there's many ways that
we can do this you can start by by
getting the king over to f6 for example
and now let's let's get the knights f7
so boom 94 i like
94 i like and if king f8 what should we
do
this is really not hard how do we get
the knight to f7 without allowing the
king to escape
no knight d6 is faster yeah 96 you could
also go 95 by the way it
the king is in a box right so so you
don't want to panic all of a sudden if
the king is like you you accidentally
allow the king one step
closer to the direction you don't want
to allow it usually you can use your
miners to shut it back down but knight
d6 is the clinical okay the w begins
the method i'm teaching you is not the
fastest don't go to table base and say
oh there's a method that 10 move faster
this is the easiest in my opinion okay
now we need to use the bishop to cover
the g8 square well how do we do that
well there's only one way to do that we
play bishop h7 now after king eight
listen very carefully because this is
the moment where almost everybody makes
a mistake almost everybody that i have
taught this mate automatically plays
this move
because there is this instinct to it
like because you have the instinct to
get opposition but this is
counterproductive because you started
dance and the black game goes back to f8
and hopefully you can understand that
you've now
almost left the king back into the open
with king g7 so if you do this mistake a
lot of people then panic and make a
random move just go back you can repeat
moves once it's not a drop you go back
to f6
now after king e8 what do you do
yeah you play 95.
now in this position there is a fork in
the road and this is the only
two things you have to know once you
learn both of these you're golden
everything is super easy if black goes
back to f8 this is the cooperative move
why is it cooperative because it lets
you complete the w in a very orderly
fashion what do you do the knight d7
check
now after king e8
again yeah now you want to go king e6 so
you're like but didn't you say it's w it
shouldn't it be knight c5 no but now
you've left the king to d8 to use your
common sense
you never want to let the king out into
the open under one exception which i'll
show in just a moment
now you go king e6 black ghost king d8
what do we do now well now we don't want
to let the king here so we go king d6
now we go king d6
the king goes back to e8 and the process
repeats itself what do we do now we give
a check on g6
and after king d this is another moment
where a lot of people stumble
the best thing to do is to make a
waiting move you want to keep
shepherding the king in the right
direction
so you just make a waiting move
forcing the king to c8 now the w
continues with knight c5
hopefully you're starting to sense a
pattern here if king d8 the w is
complete you go knight b7
king c6
that's it king b6
bishop e6 waiting move and now there's
maiden two who can tell me what the mate
is
uh and don't expect yourself to fully
understand this the very first time
you're seeing it like i don't really
understand why you're making this like
you should understand this the framework
of this without necessarily
understanding exactly why every move is
made
yeah knight c5 king b8 and this is why
you can only checkmate on the right
square because otherwise
you just don't have the machinery you
can't checkmate here with a dark scored
bishop
so
if you get the king to the right corner
final phase is the easiest that's like
arranging your united bishop so that you
give checkmate so let's review that one
more time then we'll get to the the
slightly harder part which is still very
very easy so
what we were examining here is the
cooperative move which is kfa
common mistakes so let's start again
common mistakes
first common mistake is to
get is to get opposition here which just
allows the king back if you did this you
can just go back
second common mistake so people
understand this is to get go through the
w too early you need to walk your king
over
uh in in parallel with the knight
okay in parallel with the knight you
need to use your king
to stop black's king from escaping
obviously so king d8 you go king d6
third mistake is to forget about waiting
loss this is so this actually drives me
crazy
people go knight c5 here
and what happens is that they're like
well wait a second if i go king c6 now i
let the king back to e7 why is this
happening this didn't happen when you
show this mate to me reason is because
you need to make a waiting move and only
after the king moves to the side do you
go back to c5 you understand why this
doesn't happen because now
obviously like black has to make another
move and black isn't either king goes to
b8
and you get this position or the king
goes to d8 and again you go knight b7
king c6 etc
so
that's the easy
part the harder part is what happens if
black goes to d8 in this position at
first it seems that the king escapes and
that's what makes people panic they're
like oh my god that's it the king is
like walking out but here you can build
a box and it's very very easy to build a
box and the reason it's easy is because
you do the same exact thing that you do
after king f8 you still go king e6
and you still continue the w
with knight d7 right the w is a golden
method that applies anywhere the black
king goes
and this is beautiful this is actually
really pretty geometry where you can use
your knight in the bishop to build a box
again consider the escape squares
there's only one escape square which is
b5 there's only one airport you need to
shut the airport down
shut the airport down bishop d3
king c7 is forced otherwise if king b7
then you already shut the king down with
king d6 now after king c7
again you want to shut down the escape
square so a lot of people say well
bishop b5 but bishop b5 is
counterproductive because you'll need to
be able to control the e8 square after
the king goes back to d8
so the best thing to do here is bishop
b4
and that's it you've the king's 4a is is
over
king back to d8 you go king d6 and now
we're back to the right method king e8
bishop g6 check king d8 it's only been
16 moves since the very beginning by the
way it looks like a lot but it hasn't
been what do you do now could can remind
me what are uh what what is the key move
here that people forget bishop f7 a
waiting move very good knight c5
king ba king c6 and like once you've got
the kick into the corner it's easy like
bishop b6 whatever
and here again
what should white two who can tell me
the best move just wait again yeah wait
with bishop f5
force thinking to be
when you don't know what to do
ask yourself am i forgetting about a
waiting move like am i forgetting that i
could just make a wedding and that's the
whole process that that's it that's
that's the what the fuss is about well
the most of the fuss is about the
starting process and the best way to
uh the best way to understand how to get
the king into the corner is to practice
it but let's go back to to the position
that we ended on while we were
discussing that we have this position
this is going to be a good pro good test
of your ability because this is a little
bit reflected right so now
first thing you have to do is identify
where you're going with the black ink
how do you you want the black king to h1
so
the second thing to do is to reverse
engineer the w
where does the w start
and where do we need the knight given
where black's king is okay so what did i
tell you it's one square diagonally from
the mating square
so we can now draw the w
it started on c2 then it moved to d4
so we just need the knight on e2 that's
it king f1 the knight is already in the
right place 92
what do we do now and now this is the
real practice part have you understood
the concept bishop c2
king f1 is forced continue knight f4
that's it it's the same freaking thing
king e1 knight g2 check
king f3
uh king g3
bishop d3 another waiting move
knight f4
knight h3 and bishop f3 is me this is by
no means a comprehensive
like lesson on the mate it's it gives
you the basics
now
let's do one more practice position
in terms of like figuring out where
pieces belong let me think for a second
let me try to make it a little tricky
let's do one with a dark square bishop
let's do another dark square bishop so
white to plant main
okay first we need to figure out and
there's two ways to do this you can
either drive the king this way or you
can drive the king
straight it really doesn't matter
you have two possibilities
it doesn't matter which one you wanna
you wanna do i like i like these files
because they're a little bit easier to
visualize even though it's the same so
let's start with king b6 just stopping
stopping king asap
okay so first thing you do identify
escape routes okay so black skin can
escape like this
but if the king gets to ca we can just
stop it from escaping with king c6 and
now we just identify the w it starts on
c7
we go around we need to get the knight
to c7 we chart the fastest course to c7
it's like this so boom
boom
now there's a very classy move that you
can make what's the classiest move
just like stop the king from
moving around this should be sick so
temporarily lock the king up
that's it the let the process initiates
knight c7 king v8
what should white do now
again don't panic if you can't play
bishop a7
resign
right
nope no no no no whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa was knight a6 ever part
of the dumpling whoa whoa whoa
you don't make a single night move
that's not part of the w that's the
whole point if you're thinking of making
a move that's not part of the w you are
doing something wrong period
you make a waiting room that's why i
said if you're not sure ask yourself am
i forgetting about waiting making a
waiting move bishop c5 bishop a7 king d8
now knight d5
now let me try the hard defense king e8
now who can remind me
of
the right approach here
and this is the hard part because king
c8 i think everybody has already
understood 97 check blah blah blah
so we go king d6 king f7
we continue the w with 97 let me try
king g7 slightly different approach
slightly different approach we need to
box the king's escape route so what do
we do
okay where is the king escaping it's
escaping through h6
so bishop e3 stops the escape that's it
king f6
okay now maybe the hardest part of the
whole mate what should white do
what should white do here
and then i'll all the rest is easy yeah
but just again wait bishop f4 wait
waiting move it's zhug because all of
these squares are covered so the king
has to step back
but if it steps back to g7
you
you want to make a move like king e6
here
right you want to make a move like king
e6 if the king steps to f7 you want to
play bishop b5 continuing to box it in
king e8 king e6 king d8
last question what to do now
no king d6 is the mistake king d6 is the
common mistake
because king e8 yeah wait you can even
show off with a move like this if you
want this should be anywhere on this
diagonal ship c7
knight f5 that's it knight g7 the w is
complete
if black plays king g8 then you go king
f6 first and at this point it's easy
right you can just you want to make sure
that the king is
is locked up okay i guess bishop d6 is
more accurate
and again wait
wait uh double unite and waiting bishop
that's actually good the two w's maybe
i'll think of a third one
but people forget to wait like that
honestly has been my biggest mistake
when i first started teaching this to
students i wouldn't emphasize the
importance of waiting
um and in my opinion this is an easy
method it's one that you can always
reconstruct
and you have very clear hard and fast
rules that if you're not following you
know you're doing something wrong and
that to me is the most reassuring part
of a process it's like you know
whether you're doing something wrong you
have the self-checking mechanism built
in
and that's it i mean it's not the
easiest thing to remember but once you
practice this
you know a couple times you're you're
golden
then most people at like under gm level
are not going to be experts in dodging
the corners like they're going to go
pretty much straight into the corner
so just to recap the two methods of
getting the king into the corner that we
discussed
are using the bishop for close quarter
combat particularly peace assisted
opposition like this construction
and then
identifying escape routes and using your
king obviously to fill in the gaps
then shouldering and using the knight
from a distance covering key square so
like knight p5 and then and then
shouldering the king in the right
direction nudging it in the right
direction again identifying escape
routes
so like oh the king wants to go to f2
then we want arcing on f4
the king wants to go to e2 we want our
knight on c3 the king wants to go
through e1 we want our king on e3 so we
go like knight c3
and uh if the king e7 then like
opposition king d7
okay last sort of question because i
will put this on youtube why not right
um what should we do here
so what what should white play now
this this turned out better than i
thought yeah honestly this was just sort
of impromptu
bishop d5 yeah bishop d5 to prepare to
get the king to the background bishop
said remember peace assistant opposition
it should be six wall the king in
and then
let me go to this corner
alright so
again
you follow the process w is drawn
you want to get the king to the to this
corner the w is drawn like this or i
guess like this technically
so what
you have to it's like a train right
it's like which station do you want to
hop on to
well you need to hop on a station and
you want to not let the night uh
the king escape so you're thinking okay
well where can i how can i do this
how can i do this
it's a little bit awkward right because
you're you're like king and bishop are
slightly on the wrong
sides
so the best thing to do probably this is
actually not so easy let me think for a
second
boom boom boom boom
okay i think i know what i want to do
what i would do here is i would start by
getting the knight into the center
i would start by getting the knight into
the center
now what i would do
is i would i would try to switch places
because see the what's the issue well
the issue is that if you move the knight
too far away the king's gonna escape via
c7
so we moved the bishop
let's say to
f5
okay
if king f8 i would actually go bishop g6
it not the fastest but this allows you
to then
get the knight around and start the w
that's it we started the w the rest is
easy
right king e8 95 blah blah blah
so as soon as you have an opportunity to
reinitiate the w you do it if the king
goes to d8 it's a little bit harder
but here i would go king e6
and if kc8 then you've already
shouldered again you can almost always
box the king in like this
king d6 king a6
bishop d7
king c5 and bishop c8 check so once the
king approaches the corner you can
almost transfer from one side of the
word to the other you have to have a
little bit of like freedom in how you do
it if you get the wrong type of
construction
but
there's many many ways to do it
and if the king goes to e8
then i guess i would go like 97.
get the gun 97
or maybe even i would go
huh
what would i do here i'm trying to find
i know like
how i would do it but i'm trying to find
a pure way maybe king d6 yeah king this
king d6
yeah it's the wrong w but it like in
this case it doesn't matter you can you
can almost like do it impromptu
you can do it like this and then like
this
the bottom line is that you're trying to
get the king closer to the corner so if
you've identified a way
for sure that you can force the king to
the right corner just do it
but this is very rare you usually get a
situation where you can initiate the w
in a pure way
and this is why practicing is good
eventually you'll just master oh i can
just do this little maneuver that gets
the king closer to the right side
that's where i'll end guys that's that's
enough i'll put this on youtube
hopefully this helps this is not the
nerdisk definitive method but this was
totally impromptu and
hopefully it helps a little bit
demystify things just a tiny bit
and i don't even know the two nights in
pond made so there are mates i don't
i've never even learned so plenty
plenty of such methods okay um that's
that's it guys
thanks everybody
and uh have a good one bye
[Music]
you